[Music]
let's go to chris in my hometown
nashville tennessee what's up chris
hey dr john how are you i'm good man
what's
up uh so
i i feel a little weird just asking this
because i feel like it's just such a non
problem but
hey so listen don't ever feel weird
about asking questions man i'm glad i'm
glad you're i don't even know what
you're about to ask i'm glad you're
brave enough to ask it that's awesome
i appreciate it so i've been married for
just over a year now
and it's been absolutely incredible i
really feel like my wife's my best
friend and i really couldn't have asked
for a better
first year of marriage and so
my question is just is it okay that i
don't really desire any
new friendships because of how much i
enjoy spending time with my wife
i just hear you often on this show
include having like separate friend
groups like going out and hanging out
with your buddies or going out with the
girlfriends that's like an ideal in a
marriage and
not only do i not really have that but
i'm just not really motivated to pursue
that like whenever i'm invited to spend
time with other people i just kind of
think why would i do that when i can
just spend time with her instead
so i'm wondering if that's an issue
that's going to cause problems with me
or with us later or if it's just like a
season of life that we're in and it's
nothing to worry about
i'm just i'm confused if that's
something that i even need to so dude
number one don't ever feel weird about
asking that question that's a great
question um i spoke about friendship and
love to 3 000 business leaders a couple
weeks ago
and
um
i got one negative review and it said i
don't need none of this crap
and i thought
man this whole talk was for you the rest
i mean every everybody else was escorted
through the roof one guy's like i don't
need none of this nonsense so let me let
me
let me explain it to you this way maybe
this will help
um let's say you've got your first job
out of college
and
you um
take a job as a project manager first
job out of college at a teeny tiny
little company
and the first week you're there
the company goes public and raises a
billion dollars
and you didn't know this but
when you signed up for this company you
had 25 equity stake in the outcome
so overnight you're a multi-multi-multi
multi-millionaire
it's incredible
okay right
this job is so good
and you think to yourself dude i am 22
years old i don't need a
cute little app
and i don't need a cute little uh
budget i have
250 million dollars in my checking
account
right i don't need this stuff
and
so you just go about your life
and you put a whole bunch of it in
bitcoin you put a whole bunch of it into
your friend butts um new business and
then you buy a bunch of speculative real
estate
and and so on and so forth and then all
of a sudden you look up six years from
now and the economy collapses and you
got zero
because you didn't save it in a smart
way and you didn't
you didn't continue to you have a bunch
of ferraris that you can't afford the
gas on and you got seven houses that
nobody can afford the rent on right so
suddenly you find yourself in an
absolute mess
and so
other people are your emergency fund for
life
you have had a remarkable first year and
dude it sounds like you married an
incredible woman like high five to you
man that's so great and that also means
you must be a pretty incredible guy
right
you'll have something special and it's
wonderful and i love that and i want you
to continue to nurture that friendship
what i've seen happen over and over and
over and this is in the research over
and over and over and in the reality
is the vast majority of my helping quote
unquote helping folks behind closed
doors are people who are leaders of
things they run stuff they manage things
they're the bigwigs in your community
and over time what happens pebble by
pebble by pebble
is they drown their spouse
in their friendship
they drown their they their spouse
slowly over times becomes the person
they tell all their dreams to and all
the bad stuff
and they tell all the burdens and all
that's good to share and be honest
but man
she can't carry that and the romance and
her own dreams and her all the sudden um
the weight of being with you is too much
that's why we are designed to live in
tribes and groups and people
right in multiple people who so that
guy's got the that guy's got the food
she's got the shelter
those three are taking care of the kids
like we're designed to
lean on multiple people
and you my friend are growing up in an
era where
um
marriage has taken on a new life it's
taken on a new um existential weight
meaning
up until about a hundred years ago maybe
200 years ago marriage was like
um for people to expand their empire
like they hook their kids up for
political gain or for financial gain or
um like i was a peasant and um my wife
was a peasant and we're like hey you
want to do miserable life together for a
few years until we die
all right and what happened now uh my
grandparents were married for
70-something years
and
she thought he was cute and he thought
she was cute but
over time
they did life together he was in the war
she stayed at home they raised kids they
did life together and after 72 years
they were soul mates because they they
took the same breath
and what now what my generation and
younger we've been
sold a lie which is we're trying to
reverse engineer soulmate first and
trying to do life second it doesn't work
like that and so what i'll tell you is
this
cherish your wife
and know that the data tells me that
when our bodies recognize that we are
alone
that we don't have people in our corner
or maybe we got just one person in our
corner
it will sound the alarms and the alarms
over time
show up in the form of dementia they
show up in the form of psychosis
of stroke heart attack cardiovascular
disease
you will die younger
is what the data tells me okay so
you've had a magical year your job went
public and you made a whole bunch of
money i want you to steward that money
well
so invest in her
and give her a break
invest in you
make sure you've got other friends to do
stuff with that you can be open with
that you can say is this wise or not
wise and then she'll become but a voice
in in the chorus that is the wisdom that
gets that walks alongside you in the
world she's not the only voice you're
hearing does that make sense
definitely so let me ask you this
have you always been a lone ranger just
kind of doing life alone or is this
relatively new or are i mean are you
married and you're like y'all are just
hooking up all i mean it's just awesome
year i mean tell me where you are how
did this happen
so i
have never had a lot of friends i've
never been a person to have a massive
friend group i've typically kept it to
like one to three to five okay really
close people in my life and i've had
that in every season in high school and
in college
and sort of when i really
initially when i met my wife those
friends that i had at that time i met
her in college and they kind of
dissolved away because i was spending
all my time with her and that
has basically been the case since then
we've been together now for three and a
half years and it's it's really been the
case does she have friends
she it was basically the same way she
had friends in college that she brought
over from high school but again when we
got together we we really seized
so what new relationships one of my
counseling professors
told me something profound it was great
never thought of it she said most people
wait to go to therapy until there's a
crisis until it's almost all over
and she said
how amazing would it be and she said
it's like starting a workout program at
a local gym the day you wake up with the
flu she's like doesn't make any sense
she said if your marriage is perfect
that's when y'all should start working
on some of the things you would love to
see different
and so what i would tell you is this
somebody in your marriage needs to sit
down and it can be you and say
i love you more than
the the
the sunshine in the sky like write our
poem i don't care but let her know that
you love her and let her know
that over the last couple of years
the intensity of your love has
y'all just kept rowing this boat
together and you've ended up on an
island
and the island's not safe for your
marriage because y'all are gonna have a
moment when there's a crack in the every
marriage goes through hard stuff right
um
i've got one
i don't see this lightly i've
i don't know a lot of people has got a
good marriage as i do and it has
almost come apart several times okay
like almost like i think this is over
right
i've done stupid stuff she's perfect in
all ways and all that kind of stuff
because she can't defend herself but
all i had to say is
there will come moments that you need to
um you need outside support and love and
care and so there is no better time no
better time than right now when things
are great that you all say hey we need
to start doing stuff with other couples
um i'm gonna get a group of four or five
guys we're gonna start i don't know what
you do play dungeons and dragons or go
bowling or go hunting i don't care what
the thing is and i we're gonna make it a
goal that we're each gonna have a couple
of people that we hang out with on the
side and we're gonna cultivate those
friendships and you're gonna do it
here's the thing even when you don't
want to
so
i have a rule
that when
my friend blake sends the text around
hey i'm getting the fights
almost always tonight the fights are
coming tonight y'all show up it starts
at nine o'clock i like to go to bed at
nine because i'm a nerd
and i exhale
and my rule is if my first thought is i
think i'm just gonna go to bed i have to
go i have to go that's the rule and
never not one time not one time have i
ever regretted not going and my wife
says
you are better when you are with other
people
the time we spend together maybe less in
hours because you spent those hours with
those guys
but you were more at peace and you
laughed more and you were more present
with me and i didn't have to hear about
all of your conspiracy theories i could
just hear about two of them right or all
of you or whatever
please go get friends so let me tell you
this they answer your question
yes
you have to cultivate
connection and community outside of your
marriage
everybody has to have a group that they
hang out with and do life with and let
me be totally honest with you
since i started this job
i've done a terrible job at that
and now the my book is out the show's
doing great i am i've been all i've been
on the road now i'm off
now i found myself oh crap i gotta start
over again
i gotta find a group of guys to hang out
with and i can do it on the regular and
i'm gonna it means i have to budget
differently i'm gonna have to budget my
time differently all
here we are here we are and so i found
this i must find myself with you chris
is what i'm saying and i'm committed to
going to make this thing right and i
want to challenge you and your wife if
you want the best marriage possible both
of you have to have friends